hinter mir liegt der eingang zum jet
tokamak dem derzeit größten
fusionsreaktor der welt er erzeugt
klassement mit einer temperatur von mehr
als 100 millionen grad celsius fünfmal
so heiß wie im inneren der sonne es ist
der heißeste ort im ganzen sonnensystem
[Musik]
es ist ein globales projekt der
superlative
der schutz der umwelt und das
wohlergehen aller stellen uns vor
besondere technologische
herausforderungen mit hochdruck und
leidenschaft arbeiten wissenschaftler
daran eine bessere welt zu gestalten
ich tue es für meine kinder ich bin
davon überzeugt dass das der richtige
weg ist
[Musik]
eine saubere welt in zukunft gibt es
bessere methoden heißt das verbrennen
fossiler brennstoffe
eine grünere welt
dieser windpark produziert mehr strom
als alle windparks und großbritannien
und wahrscheinlich auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
was wir bisher gemacht haben wird nicht
mehr reichen es gibt bessere wege wir
müssen jetzt einen schritt nach vorne
machen und neue technologien einsetzen
gemeinsam gehen sie an die grenzen der
wissenschaft um außergewöhnliche
maschinen zu erschaffen die unseren
planeten schützen können für die zukunft
[Musik]
es könnte die größte technologische
herausforderung in der geschichte der
menschheit sein das streben nach einer
lösung für die energieversorgung
nach einer zuverlässigen
unerschöpflichen quelle für sauberen
strom
windmühlen sind was feines solaranlagen
auch aber beide funktionieren nicht wenn
der wind nicht weht oder die sonne nicht
scheint was wäre wenn wir hier auf der
erde so etwas wie eine kleine sonne
erschaffen könnten eine maschine die
strom erzeugt mit kernfusion
wenn die kernfusion funktioniert können
wir damit unseren basis energiebedarf
wir ersetzen die kohlekraftwerke und
stoßen keine treibhausgase im haus das
potenzial ist
die kernfusion bietet der menschheit
eine nahezu unbegrenzte energiequelle
aber es gibt große herausforderungen die
meisten davon technischer art
seit über 70 jahren suchen forscher
weltweit nach lösungen der kalte krieg
machte den austausch zwischen ost und
west schwierig das projekt ist
gigantisch das ziel einen strom
erzeugenden fusionsreaktor zu bauen ist
bislang noch wunschdenken
was wird benötigt extrem hohe
temperaturen
magnetfelder wie es sie auf der erde
noch nie gegeben hat und die fähigkeit
beides über lange zeiträume
aufrechtzuerhalten
wenn man sich den energiebedarf der welt
anschaut ist fusion nur eine frage der
zeit
die bisher erfolgreichste testanlage ist
im englischen kader
hier finden entscheidende versuche statt
[Musik]
um dem konzept eines fusionsreaktors
mehr zu kommen gehen die forscher an die
grenzen von wissenschaft und technologie
und darüber hinaus wenn sie erfolg haben
könnte das projekt unsere welt verändern
jeder tag ist spannend eine premiere
nach der ein großes abenteuer sind wir
sind auf dem weg zu einem wichtigen ziel
für die menschheit
[Musik]
die tests sind nur ein kleiner teil
einer ganz großen sache
[Musik]
seit über einem jahrzehnt läuft in der
französischen provence ein riesiges
bauprojekt
in wenigen monaten sollen an dieser
stelle die teile eines nie dagewesenen
technologischen puzzle zusammengesetzt
werden
[Musik]
die kosten
22 milliarden dollar damit das teuerste
wissenschaftliche experiment in der
geschichte der menschheit
sein name peter kurz für internationaler
thermonukleare experimental reaktor
etwas so großes und teures ist noch nie
versucht worden
die 42 hektar große plattformen ist 400
meter breit und vergleichbar mit der
fläche von 60 fußballfeldern
wenn dieses projekt erfolg hat könnte
eine neue ära für die zukünftige
energieproduktion anbrechen
eine riesige maschine die sich eines
prozesses auf sub atomarer ebene bedient
eines prozesses der die energie für die
bausteine des lebens liefert die
kernfusion
[Musik]
unsere welt ist das ergebnis einer
supernova eines alten stern die
supernova wiederum entstand durch eine
fusionsreaktion
als wissenschaftler finde ich
fantastisch was wir hier machen wir sind
sozusagen dabei die grundlagen der natur
nachzubauen
im innern unserer sonne läuft wieder und
wieder derselbe prozess ab wasserstoff
atome schließen sich zusammen und
fusionieren
dabei werden riesige mengen an energie
freigesetzt
seine energie bezieht ein atom aus dem
was uns zusammenhält der sogenannten
bindungsenergie
um ein atom zu spalten braucht man jede
menge energie
immer sonniger erbes in omsk aufgrund
der enormen gravitation wird der
wasserstoff in der sonne stark erhitzt
und komprimiert bei einer kollision
besteht daher die möglichkeit dass atome
aneinander haften bleiben sie kleben k
weise zusammen bis man hilfe erhält
das helium hat etwas weniger
bindungsenergie als der ursprüngliche
wasserstoff energie differenz wird als
wärme freigesetzt und als licht das
licht das von der sonne und den sternen
bei uns ankommt pro sekunde verbraucht
die sonne etwa 600 millionen tonnen
wasserstoff
damit erzeugt sie eine halbe million mal
mehr energie als in einem ganzen jahr
auf der erde verbraucht wird
die sonne strahlten und deshalb so stark
weil sie so groß ist sie ist nämlich
eigentlich unglaublich ineffizient ein
kubikmeter der sonne produziert nur 30
watt energie könnten sie und ich
produzieren pro kubikmeter mehr wärme
als die sonne die sonne ist nur so heiß
weil sie so riesig ist
der prozess der kernfusion wird mit dem
apfel eines sterns in eine flasche
verglichen
tatsächlich muss die fusion auf der erde
noch weit mehr leisten als ein stern
in der sonne findet eine fusion des
leichtesten bekannten elemente statt
wasserstoff wenn wir eine schwere
version verwenden leute helium oder
tritium läuft der prozess viel schneller
und effektiver und genau das wollen wir
mit unseren fusionsreaktoren tun es ist
übrigens ganz gut dass die sonne diese
brennstoffe nicht verwendet täte sie es
wäre sie in weniger als einer sekunde
verbrannt verglichen mit denen fünf bis
zehn milliarden jahren lebensdauer die
sie tatsächlich hat
bei der fusion geht es darum ein super
heißes elektrisch geladenes gas zu
erzeugen plasma
dafür braucht man drei dinge hohe
temperatur zeit und begrenzung einen
behälter all das stellt die wissenschaft
vor große probleme
erstens wie erzeugt man temperaturen von
über 100 millionen grad
zweitens wie hält man die geladenen
kerne so lange zusammen dass sie
verschmelzen und schließlich wenn beides
geklappt hat und plasma erzeugt wurde
wie hält man eine substanz in schach die
alles was sie berührt sofort verdampfen
lässt
die forscher in england und in
frankreich glauben dass die lösung auf
einem prinzip basiert das erstmals in
den 1950 er jahren in einem sowjetischen
reaktor entwickelt wurde dem sogenannten
tokamak reaktor
[Musik]
es ist der jet der joint european torus
es ist ein tokamak ein gerät das mit
hilfe eines magnetfelds plasma bei sehr
hohen temperaturen einschließt um eine
kernfusion zu erzeugen
[Musik]
es gibt zwei magnetsysteme nein es geht
so rum uns das andere so rum
sie halten das plasma im zentrum des
vakuums weg von den wänden genauso
können wir die temperatur auf bis zu 200
millionen grad celsius erhöhen die
anlage ist ringförmig so hält das
magnetfeld das plasma davon ab sich in
eine bestimmte richtung zu bewegen es
darf keine endpunkte geben
endpunkte vermeidet man indem man die
magnet kammer ringförmig anlegt
das ist weltweiter standard magnet kann
man sehen immer aus wie donuts dieser
hier heißt zuckermarkt
[Musik]
red ist ein hoch vakuumsystem zu beginn
jedes experiment punkten wie es wäre
dann injizieren wie eine kleine menge
gas in die kammer bestehend aus
deuterium und tritium in beiden
wasserstoff isotopen die wir für die
fusion verwenden sie werden mit hilfe
eines starken elektrischen feldes
ionisiert das um den tokamak herum
erzeugt wird doch sobald sie ironisiert
sind leiten sie die elektrizität die
leistung im inneren beträgt bis zu
4.000.000 ampere bei solchen werten
verwandelt sich heißes gas in plasma
das gas wird also elektrisch aufgeladen
und erhitzt um plasma zu erzeugen in
diesem stadium beträgt die temperatur
aber nur zehn millionen grad celsius
das mag für die sonne reichen ohne die
größe und das gravitationsfeld der sonne
brauchen wir auf der erde zehnfach
höhere temperaturen um eine kernfusion
durchzuführen
was tun wir also sie erhitzen das plasma
zusätzlich um das zehnfache projekt hat
zwei solcher zusätzlichen heizsysteme
die durchwegs ist umsonst das eine ist
ein resonanz system ähnlich der
mikrowelle in der küche dieses system im
inneren von jet bringt eine leistung von
8 bis 10 millionen watt in das plasma
zum vergleich das ist etwa das 10.000
fache der leistung einer normalen
mikrowelle
noch allerdings das zweite zusätzliche
heizsystem ist das ist große system hier
damit indizieren wir energiereiche
neutrale atome in das plasma neutral
damit das magnetfeld sie nicht irritiert
ist dass dieses system und seine
schwester auf der anderen seite der
maschine sind in der lage mehr als 30
millionen watt in den jet zu leiten die
kombination der beiden heizsysteme
ermöglicht es uns die temperatur so zu
erhöhen dass wir eine fusion herstellen
können das problem dabei ganz egal wie
groß und ausgeklügelt jet sein mag die
erzeugung des plasmas verbraucht so viel
energie dass die bilanz des reaktors am
ende allenfalls neutral ausfällt
wissenschaftler vergleichen das mit dem
entzünden eines feuers man benutzt ein
streichholz um es in gang zu setzen aber
letztlich muss das feuer von selbst
weiter brennen hier braucht man viel
mehr so genanntes brennendes plasma um
die temperatur hoch zu halten
und genau da kommt ins spiel
[Musik]
da ist der nächste schritt dafür nutzen
wir das gesamte wissen rund um die
existierenden maschine für jedes wort
das wir hinein stecken wollen wir zehn
aus der fusionsreaktion heraus
das hat noch keiner geschafft es gab
bereits exzellente berechnungen die
durch experimente bestätigt wurden aber
niemand hat sich an das niveau heran
gewagt dass ein zukünftiges kraftwerk
für die fusion erreichen müsste
[Musik]
das ist eine der wirklich großen
physikalischen herausforderungen es wäre
das erste mal dass wir tatsächlich
brennendes plasma erzeugt
[Musik]
das brennende plasma könnte verwendet
werden um durch rohre fließendes wasser
zu erhitzen
das heiße wasser wiederum könnte
turbinen antreiben genau wie in einem
herkömmlichen kraftwerk
mit nur 250 kilogramm deuterium und
tritium könnte man eine million
haushalte ein jahr lang mit strom
versorgen für die gleiche leistung
benötigt ein kohlekraftwerk
2,7 millionen tonnen kohle
terium ist reichlich vorhanden
es kann aus meerwasser destilliert
werden
petition wird die sache komplizierter
kriterium und tritium sind zwei
verschiedene arten von wassersport mit
dem wasserstoff ist das erste element im
periodensystem aber es gibt drei
verschiedene arten ist die normale
variante mehr als 99 prozent des
wasserstoffs auf der erde ist emotion
und ihn dann gibt es dort eher ii um
oder schweren wasserstoff und tritium
ist noch mal schwerer tritium ist
radioaktiv es zerfällt mit einer
halbwertszeit von etwas über zehn jahren
deshalb gibt es nicht sehr viel davon
auf der erde tatsächlich beträgt der
gesamte welt vorrat an tritium nur etwa
20 kilogramm das meiste davon wird durch
die wiederaufbereitung von verbrauchtem
kernbrennstoff aus konventionellen
spaltung reaktoren gewonnen
wir umgehen dieses problem indem wir
unser eigenes tritium herstellen wir
geben lithium in die hülle des
fusionsreaktors die neutronen die durch
die fusion erzeugt werden spalten das
lithium und erzeugen tritium
so stellen wir mehr tritium her als wir
verbrennen wir geben es dann zurück in
den reaktor und erhalten etwas das
deuterium und lithium als brennstoff
verwendet lithium ist ein rohstoff und
kann abgebaut werden wieder terium ist
es auch mehr wasser enthalten und frei
zugänglich
wenn mieter erfolgreich sein will muss
er sich selber mit tritium versorgen
können
einmal fertiggestellt wird etat der
größte und teuerste fusionsreaktor mit
einem gewicht von 23.000 tonnen wird er
dreimal so schwer sein wie der
eiffelturm und dann sind da noch die
magnete sie sind unerlässlich um das
brennende plasma im zaum und seine
immense hitze von den wänden des
behälters fernzuhalten
jede der 18 ringförmigen magnetspulen
wird so viel wiegen wie eine voll
beladene boeing 747
zusammen mit weiteren sechs rund
magneten
48 meter breit und bis zu 400 tonnen
schwer werden sie eine kraft ausüben die
der doppelten schubkraft eines space
shuttles beim start entspricht
und das alles mit dem ziel große mengen
an plasma zu erzeugen und zu
kontrollieren wenn wasserstoff zu plasma
ionisiert wird leuchtet er wunderschön
rosa eine regelrechte aura es fühlt sich
an als würde man gleichzeitig forschen
und ein kunstwerk erschaffen
um die starken elektromagnetischen
felder zu erzeugen die das plasma
zusammenhalten kommen beim etat
einzigartige magnete zum einsatz ihre
entwicklung begann vor 30 jahren der
leiter der magnet abteilung ist
nietzsche ein mann der von anfang an
dabei ist
[Musik]
das ist etwas sehr persönliches
ich habe nicht bloß meine karriere
sondern mein ganzes leben mit diesem
projekt verbrannt
[Musik]
es ist sehr befriedigend wenn man denkt
das haben wir da vor 25 jahren auf ein
stück papier gezeichnet so sieht das
also in wirklichkeit aus der meinung sie
jetzt nimmt das nun wirklich alles
gestalt an
sind diese website
[Musik]
die elektromagnete die hier zum einsatz
kommen werden supraleiter genannt sie
arbeiten bei unglaublichen niedrigen
temperaturen bei denen ihre drehte
keinen elektrischen widerstand haben
sobald der magnet aufgeladen ist
verbraucht er nur so viel strom wie
dafür benötigt wird ihn zu kühlen
das magnetsystem von ita hat eine große
menge energie gespeichert etwa 40
gigajoule falls gigajoule ihnen etwas
sagt aber wahrscheinlich nicht das
reicht für mehrere kilowatt leistung für
zwei oder drei tage es steckt eine menge
energie in den magneten aber sie wird
nicht verbraucht man fügt sie hinzu und
sie bleibt gespeichert die ströme
zirkulieren immer weiter praktisch
kostenlos ein gigajoule entspricht der
kapazität von vier elektroautos mit
großer reichweite
das magnetsystem speichert also das
äquivalent von etwa 160 vollgeladenen
elektrofahrzeugen
wer stellt solche außergewöhnlichen
geräte her vor etat betrug die weltweite
produktion von supraleitern nur 20
tonnen pro jahr
peters magnetsystem bringt es dagegen
auf unglaubliche 10.000 tonnen
die supraleitenden magnete für iter
fordern uns besonders ich bin seit 30
jahren in der branche die ita magnete
sind bei weitem das komplexeste an dem
ich je gearbeitet habe
aber es ist nicht nur ihre komplexität
ihre schiere größe macht es nahezu
unmöglich sie auf regulären straßen zu
transportieren
man braucht also eine fabrik sehr nah am
meer
leichter gesagt als getan um sich den
idealen standort zu sichern hat die
italienische firma cmk die
produktionsstätten eines spülmaschinen
herstellers übernommen
[Musik]
der deal enthielt die vereinbarung dass
sie den großteil der alten belegschaft
einstellen muss
produziert wird nun modernste
technologie vom ct scanner bis zur
magnetschwebebahn
[Musik]
the chain fest die leute wurden erst
geschult dann begann die zusammenarbeit
nach zwei jahren war ein hoch
motiviertes qualifiziertes team
entstanden ein wichtiger faktor ist die
motivation
[Musik]
dass es bei diesem projekt darum geht
saubere und erneuerbare energie zu
produzieren und hoffentlich die zukunft
des planeten zu retten war sicher ein
grund warum alles so schnell gehen
[Musik]
jeder der 18 ring magnete hat eine fast
5 km lange induktionsspule
diese wiederum enthalten jeweils 1400
supraleitende drähte aus 17 und kupfer
sie müssen mit großer präzision zu einer
spirale gewickelt werden
[Musik]
das von robotern geschweißte gehäuse ist
15 kilometer lang die magnete werden in
harz eingewickelt isoliert und vakuum
versiegelt
[Musik]
sie enthalten auch kühl rohre durch die
flüssiges helium fließt
[Musik]
die magnete müssen jahrelang gekühlt
werden die notwendige temperatur beträgt
minus 269 grad celsius nur vier grad
über dem absoluten nullpunkt die
kälteste temperatur überhaupt
ist der reaktor erst in betrieb wird
sein zentrum der heißeste ort im ganzen
sonnensystem sein
nur wenige meter davon entfernt ist es
extrem kalt lediglich zwei grad wärmer
als die niedrigste temperatur des
universums diese herrschten etwa 5000
lichtjahren entfernung von der erde im
sogenannten bumerang niebel wie lassen
sich so niedrige temperaturen erreichen
[Musik]
dafür muss die größte helium kälteanlage
der welt gebaut werden die kälte zu
erzeugen ist das eine sie konstant zu
halten das andere die wissenschaftler
müssen einen weg finden den reaktor zu
isolieren die lösung ein vakuum gefäß
bestehend aus drei riesigen edelstahl
bauteilen bekannt als kroos tat
wir sind jetzt in der kreisstadt
werkstatt
hier wird der größte kühlschrank aller
zeiten gebaut
[Musik]
wir betreten jetzt sogar vor sich kopf
einziehen den oberen zylinder
bis 10
hier sieht und spürt man die dimensionen
der anlage
30 meter breit und 30 meter hoch es ist
aber das ist nur das obere drittel ein
wahres monster ist
[Musik]
bei einem projekt wie es scheint sich
alles um wissenschaft und technik zu
drehen aber es gibt auch einen
politischen aspekt schließlich sind 35
nationen beteiligt die mehr als die
hälfte der weltbevölkerung
repräsentieren
sabine groß und ihr team wissen nur zu
gut dass bei einem so langfristigen
projekt regierungen kommen und gehen
werden wie lässt sich sicherstellen dass
neue staatschefs dem traum von der
fusion verpflichtet bleiben
vermutlich würde ein einzelnes
großunternehmen viel schneller
vorankommen als so ein internationales
konglomerat aber wäre das tatsächlich
die bessere strategie
denn hier geht es um etwas größeres
[Musik]
warum 35 ländern wir sagen immer dass
zwei hauptziele hat
diese anlage zu bauen und damit zu
beweisen dass wir energie erzeugen
können indem wir atome fusionieren
all diese nationen an bord zu haben so
bauen wir als nebeneffekt eine weltweite
fusions industrie auf
ist das zentrum der forschung darauf ist
zunächst alles ausgerichtet zugleich ist
es ein ausgangspunkt für die anderen
länder um später ihre eigenen maschine
zu bauen
[Musik]
die produktion all der verschiedenen
bauteile koordiniert connecticut davor
war sie 18 jahre lang physikerin in
kallham
bei diesem projekt arbeiten wir mit
millionen von komponenten aus der ganzen
welt
das schwierigste daran ist für mich die
kommunikation
können sie sich vorstellen wie viele
probleme bei einem zeitplan mit einer
viertelmillion aktivitäten und täglichen
meilensteinen auftauchen
was hat vorrang was ist wirklich wichtig
welche sind die 5 oder 15 punkte um die
wir uns als erstes kümmern müssen
wie unterteil wir das größte und
komplizierteste bauprojekt der welt in
verständliche einzelteile
schwimmen und standen
zum glück können die kolleginnen und
kollegen hier jedes problem lösen sie
wissen wirklich was sie tun
[Musik]
wo so viele menschen aus so
unterschiedlichen ländern zusammenkommen
wo so viele sprachen gesprochen und
dinge erforscht werden ist ein ort
besonders wichtig für die kommunikation
[Musik]
die kantine
sich einfach nur zum essen hinsetzen ein
wenig plaudern und genauso sind sprachen
entstand sie wurden nicht für das
klassenzimmer entwickelt sondern für
einfache praktische situation
immer wieder dieselben einfachen sätzen
so kommt man sich näher und stellt auch
mal eine frage wenn etwas unklar ist
[Musik]
können wir schon ist die konversation
verändert sich das ansieht
gesichtsausdrücken die esten nach einer
weile versteht man auch die nuancen
einer sprache
komme ich zu einem bei eta zu arbeiten
ist wie alle länder der welt zu besuchen
die länder der welt sind gekommen um
mich zu besuchen eine sehr einfache art
zu reisen es ist vielleicht nur ein
mittags aber dabei treffen ideen auf
einfühlsam ungleich geäußert von
chinesen die von japanern von all den
verschiedenen nationalitäten die am
tisch sitzen
das it projekt zum fortschrittlichsten
was die moderne technologie zu bieten
habt
tatsächlich aber ist das konzept der
kernfusion bereits ein jahrhundert alt
1920 schlägt der britische astrophysiker
verdingten vor dass sterne ihre
scheinbar endlose energie aus der fusion
von wasserstoff zu helium beziehen
14 jahre später gelingt dem in
neuseeland geborenen physiker ernest
rutherford bekannt für seine arbeiten
zur spaltung des atoms die erste
gezielte durchführung einer kern
fusionsreaktion
[Musik]
im lauf der geschichte hat die fusion
einige höhen und tiefen durchlaufen zum
beispiel damals als die wissenschaftler
zum ersten mal versuchten zu verstehen
wie die sonne funktioniert da war die
begeisterung zunächst groß aber bald
wurde klar dass das ziemlich kompliziert
war
[Musik]
in den 50er jahren wurde dann die idee
des magnetischen einschluss entwickelt
sie löste großen enthusiasmus aus sehr
schnell wieder abflaute sobald sie
perfektioniert ist wird uns die fusions
kraft einen unbegrenzten vorrat an
energie liefern
wir lernen sie zu perfektionieren aber
selbst die optimistischsten
wissenschaftler glauben dass die fusions
kraft erst in 50 jahren entwickelt sein
wird
in den frühen 1960 er jahren kommt die
forschung ins stocken
zahlreiche anfänglich viel versprechende
experimentelle wege haben keine
brauchbaren ergebnisse gebracht
die unterstützung aus der politik
beginnt zu schwinden
doch 1968 geschieht etwas
bemerkenswertes
rasch den russischen wissenschaftlern
gelang ein großer durchbruch und das war
der talker mark
die sowjetische anlage übertrifft die
leistung ähnlicher maschinen um
mindestens das zehnfache
die ergebnisse sind so spektakulär dass
manche von fehlerhaften messungen
sprechen
also wird ein team von britischen
wissenschaftlern die einen ähnlichen
reaktor entwickelt haben zu einem
unabhängigen test eingeladen
[Musik]
damals wurde nicht nur der töpfermarkt
der internationalen gemeinschaft
präsentiert es war auch die
geburtsstunde einer offenen
zusammenarbeit
plötzlich war der kalte krieg gar nicht
mehr so kalt ich die russen sagten hey
schaut mal wir haben ein ergebnis die
ganze welt sah sich das an und die
russin teilten ihre erfahrung es war ein
offener und positiver austausch das
finde ich so cool an der fusion sie ist
grenzenlos
[Musik]
november 1985 ein weiterer meilenstein
in der geschichte der fusion inmitten
der spannungen des kalten krieges
treffen der russische präsident
gorbatschow und us präsident reagan auf
dem berühmten genfer gipfel erstmals
zusammen
[Musik]
gorbatschow on trading suchten nach
wegen für eine friedliche zusammenarbeit
sie beschlossen die kräfte zu bündeln
und gemeinsam eine internationale anlage
zu entwickeln die die probleme der
fusion lösen sollte diesen beschluss
verdanken wir ihm
im laufe der jahre wird die
zusammenarbeit immer wieder auf die
probe gestellt besonders beim bau des
vakuum gefäßes es ist das herzstück des
reaktors und soll das brennende plasma
einschließen
es besteht aus neuen gigantischen
segmenten
[Musik]
fünf davon werden in europa hergestellt
4 in korea
mit einer doppelschicht aus stahl wiegt
jedes segment hunderte tonnen
[Musik]
trotz der enormen größe kommt es bei der
konstruktion auf den millimeter an
da so viele unternehmen aus
verschiedenen ländern beteiligt sind
sind planung und logistik extrem wichtig
[Musik]
fast die hälfte aller komponenten kommt
aus europa deshalb wird eigens eine
organisation namens fusion for energy
gegründet sie soll die internationale
zusammenarbeit erleichtern und die
entwicklung neuer produktionsverfahren
ermöglichen damit das internationale
großprojekt möglichst reibungslos
umgesetzt werden kann
beim thema fusion kann einem schon ein
bisschen schwindlig werden
[Musik]
obwohl ich es jeden tag mache ist für
mich immer noch kaum vorstellbar dass
wir hier plasma auf 150 millionen grad
erhitzen
der größte teil des plasmas ist während
des fusionsprozesses in einem
magnetischen käfig eingeschlossen es
werden aber auch neutronen freigesetzt
einerseits ist das gewollt schließlich
liefern sie die wärmeenergie aber wie
der name schon sagt sind sie neutral
geladen
der magnet kann sie andererseits also
nicht in schach halten neutronen sind
unglaublich schnell gebe es keine
hindernisse könnten sie den mond in nur
acht sekunden erreichen
treffen neutronen ständig gegen die wand
des plasma behälters kann das mit der
zeit schäden verursachen ein problem das
noch während der bauarbeiten gelöst
werden musste und zwar von den
kolleginnen und kollegen die in england
am gad reaktor arbeiten
wissen sofort erwähnt sei das ist ein
foto vom inneren des jet ungefähr ein
halber größe in wirklichkeit ist es
doppelt so groß das vermittelt einen
eindruck davon wie die innenwände des
reaktors aussehen
früher waren die kacheln auf der
innenseite des reaktors aus kohlenstoff
kohlenstoff ist sehr flexibel
oder experimenten an der
belastungsgrenze ließ er sich überhitzen
ohne dass die kachel ihrer form
verändert
wo ist das problem mit kohlenstoff ist
dass er mit wasserstoff reagiert er
reagiert mit helium und tritium und den
brennstoffen des plasmas
dabei schließt er sie im inneren der
anlage ein was tun wir also statt
kohlenstoff verwenden wir mithalten
das testmaterial in den reaktor zu
bekommen ist schwerer als man denkt im
reaktor herrscht nämlich radioaktive
strahlung außerdem darf er nicht
verunreinigt werden alles was in der
kammer passiert muss von außen
ferngesteuert werden
[Musik]
das ist unser kontrollraum von hier aus
steuern und warten wir den chat reaktor
wir brauchen ihn weil der jet die
einzige anlage auf der welt ist die mit
fusions brennstoffen arbeitet und
deshalb aktivierungs stufen im inneren
der maschine hat innerhalb des reaktors
und spricht die strahlungsmenge etwa dem
was man im lauf eines jahres auf
natürliche weise abbekommt für unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter soll
die strahlung möglichst gering gehalten
werden
[Musik]
wie viel es plätschert ist die steuerung
ein echtes einzelstück
sie wurde im lauf von 20 30 jahren
entwickelt grundlage war technologie aus
der hochenergiephysik aber davon ist
nicht viel übrig geblieben mischen sie
alles ist unglaublich präzise
wenn sie versehentlich eine kreuz
schraube reihen drehen können sie sie
wieder rausholen und stattdessen eine
schiffsschraube nehmen
die steuerung ist sehr sensibel wurde
vor etwas in der maschine gemacht wird
wird es ausgiebig am computer trainiert
so eine ausbildung dauert monate wenn
nicht jahre schienen its danach ist man
voll ausgebildeter techniker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dank der hochpräzisen fernsteuerung
können proben nicht größer als eine
stecknadel spitze entnommen und
analysiert werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am ende der testreihe fällt die wahl auf
zwei metalle zum einen berührung ein
sehr leichtes nicht reagieren das metall
das unter anderem zur herstellung von
raketen und flugzeuge eingesetzt wird
verwenden wir in der hauptkammer direkt
neben dem hochtemperatur plasma dort
herrschen jene 200 millionen grad die
für die fusion nötig sind
so stark die magnete auch sind die
diesen käfig bilden und das plasma von
der wand erhalten es gibt immer einen
gewissen verlust gemacht haben wir es so
eingerichtet dass die verluste zum boden
der maschine abgeleitet werden
zum anderen kommt wolfram zum einsatz
obwohl etwas anfälliger für reaktionen
mit wasserstoff als premium ist es doch
eines der zähesten metalle der erde im
unteren teil der maschine ist das plasma
viel kälter es hat nur 20 bis 30 tausend
grad bei solchen temperaturen darf das
plasma bei materialien mit hohen
schmelzpunkt die wolfram die wände
berühren das innere der vakuumkammer neu
zu verkleiden ist ein kraftakt
4000 kacheln müssen ausgetauscht werden
alles per fernsteuerung
[Musik]
die hier gewonnenen erkenntnisse und die
praxis sind wichtig für die zukunft des
projekts die techniker und forscher sind
nun geübt und einsatzbereit sobald der
reaktor startklar ist
bis 2025 soll ein funktionsfähiger
energie produzierender tokamak fertig
sein
kritiker weisen darauf hin dass das
internationale großprojekt immer teurer
wird und immer länger dauert
einige wissenschaftler sind der meinung
ein ganz anderer weg führe zur fusion in
den 1970 er jahren experimentieren
forscher mit starken laser strahlen sie
wollen eine kugel mit wasserstoff
isotope so stark erhitzen dass sie mit
solcher kraft inkludiert das wasserstoff
atome verschmelzen
und so funktioniert ein ultra
hochleistungslaser feiert seinen
lichtstrahl auf eine sehr kleine kugel
die in eine ziel kammer feld sie wird
von allen seiten gleichzeitig getroffen
die äußeren schichten verdampfen der
innere kern wird zusammengepresst
die implosion amt die enorme
gravitationskraft nach die sterne nutzen
um den fusionsprozess erst zu erzeugen
und dann einzudämmen die fachwelt nennt
es trägheit fusion
aber wie bei allem was mit fusion zu tun
hat liegen die dinge nicht so einfach
[Musik]
denn um wasserstoff kugeln von der größe
eines zucker würfels implodieren zu
lassen bedarf es eines lesers der zehn
stockwerke hoch und doppelt so groß wie
ein fußballfeld ist aber die geschichte
der trägheit fusion ist damit noch nicht
zu ende
[Musik]
das ist ein knall krebs was der mit
kernfusion zu tun hat sehr gute frage
nicolas hocker ist mitbegründer der
firma first light fischen ein kleines
bemerkenswertes krustentier inspirierte
ihn dazu die entstehung der trägheit
fusion aus anderer perspektive zu
betrachten
vielleicht genügt ja ein winziger
bruchteil der energie eines riesigen
laser
der krebs schnappt mit seinen scheren so
schnell zu dass sie eine akustische
schockwelle erzeugen die ihre beute
betäuben oder sogar töten kann
[Musik]
die rasante bewegung erzeugt eine
gasblase die dann mit einem lauten knall
implodiert
dabei werden luft und dampf im inneren
so stark erhitzt dass sich kurzzeitig
plasma bildet das fast so heiß wie die
sonnenoberfläche wird
es ist das einzige bekannte natürliche
beispiel für ein innerlich ein
geschlossenes plasma abgesehen von einer
supernova
beim krebs ist das plasma ein
zufallsprodukt
ein bisschen gas ein bisschen
wasserdampf und so weiter war es um das
prinzip für die fusionsenergie zu nutzen
haben geben wir dort helium und treat
jungen die blase sie werden durch das
implodieren erhitzt anstelle der schere
verwenden wir ein hochgeschwindigkeits
projekt hier
es war so sieht eines unserer ziele aus
das ist unser satz für die blase wie der
krebs erzeugt in unserer simulation
selbst in der einfachsten mit nur einer
blase sehen sie dass da eine menge
passiert
das wichtigste ist die druckwelle die
sich nach innen bewegt trifft sie auf
die blase kehrt diese sich von innen
nach außen und erzeugt einen strahl der
sich quer durch die blase bewegt und
dann auf die rückwand trifft
entscheidend ist dass der strahl sich
schneller bewegt als das projektil
das in deutsch serien und tritium im
inneren werden zusammengepresst für
einen winzigen sekundenbruchteil
entstehen enorme hitze und dichte und
einen neutronen impuls wird abgegeben
in jedes dieser ziele setzt etwa so viel
energie frei wie ein fass öl
so funktioniert das kraftwerk oder so
schießt das projektil auf das ziel es
setze energie frei diese wird
eingefangen und dann wiederholt sich das
ganze
[Applaus]
die ersten experimente werden mit einer
gas kann ohne gemacht sie schießt das
projekt fiel zwar mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 24.000 kilometer pro
stunde ab aber das ist noch nicht
schnell genug die bessere lösung
elektromagnetische abschuss geräte die
einen immensen energie impuls aus senden
das ist maschine 3 unsere neueste impuls
betrieben
ein elektromagnetischer abschluss
apparat hier drin haben wir 192
kondensator wir laden sie bis zu 100.000
volt auf voll aufgeladen haben wir
zweieinhalb megajoule gespeicherte
elektrische
was bedeutet dass diese maschine
unglaubliche 14 millionen ampere
erzeugen kann
[Musik]
von hier oben bekommt man ein viel
besseres gefühl für m3 wir haben hier
sechs kondensator batterien außen herum
angeordnet wenn wir die schalter
schließen fließt der strom über die
kondensatoren nach unten in den inneren
erreichen
ist auch hier sehen sie unsere
vakuumkammer die gerade montiert wird
sie wird mit einem deckel verschlossen
und darunter läuft alles zusammen
durch diese kreisförmige scheibe fließen
die 14 millionen ampere die dann in
diese mittelstück zusammenströmen
darin befindet sich eine weitere kleine
scheibe die sich exklusiv löst das ganze
ist aus einem guss nach unten ist eine
art not dort fließen die ströme die
scheibe fliegt und trifft das ziel
die eigentliche herausforderung besteht
darin die energie so schnell wie möglich
in lila hut zu bringen in und um das zu
schaffen müssen wir die schalter in
zehntel nanosekunden schließen sind
milliarden sie konnten sobald die
schalter geschlossen sind entlädt sich
die maschine in eineinhalb mikros in
diesem moment ist die leistung in der
ladung größer als im kompletten
stromnetz der usa so erreicht das
projekt viel geschwindigkeiten von bis
zu 20 km
also von london nach new york
so beeindruckend dieser mechanismus auch
sein mag das hauptaugenmerk der forscher
liegt darauf das innere des kleinen
zielobjekt optimal zu gestalten
sie experimentieren mit verschiedenen
größen und mengen von blasen die
interagieren um die schockwelle zu
verstärken und wenn jetzt der vorteil
unseres ansatzes ist dass der rest des
kraftwerks viel einfacher zu bauen ist
besteht fast nur aus bekannter technik
wenn wir das hinkriegen ist der weg zur
fusionsenergie einfacher und darauf
kommt es an
[Musik]
euro lag
der deckel des vakuum gefäßes wird
gelüftet
sofort wird das resultat der enormen
wenn auch flüchtigen energieproduktion
sichtbar
hier allerdings werden nur einzelne
brennstoffzellen getestet ein
funktionierendes kraftwerk müsste solche
energiemengen regelmäßig und zuverlässig
liefern
[Musik]
wir überlegen den aufprall vorgang zu
wiederholen indem wir das zielobjekt mit
hilfe der schwerkraft in eine röhre
das projektil besäße dann eine viel
größere geschwindigkeit much much higher
velocity vor das ziel wäre leicht zu
erreichen
dieses ereignis wiederholen wir alle 20
30 40 sekunden
die fotos ens in basica jedem aufprall
entsteht ein energie stoß
in order to konfusion energie in wärme
umzuwandeln
braucht man ein gerät namens blanket
in unserem reaktor konzept sind diese
blanket fallende vorhänge aus flüssigem
nation
sie erfüllen mehrere zwecke reicht wo
hast du kleiner ist die fusionsenergie
in wärme umzuwandeln die dann eine
turbine antreibt und strom erzeugt
die andere ist dass wir auf diese weise
tritium produzieren dass wir
anschließend in den prozess zurück
führen weil es eine unserer brennstoff
komponenten ist
vielen kernfusion ist machbar die wird
wirklichkeit werden kann sie kann den
klimawandel stoppen wenn wir bis 2050
kein co2 mehr ausstoßen wollen brauchen
wir 2040 zehn anlagen am netz um das zu
schaffen brauchen wir 2030 eine anlage
am netz und um das zu schaffen müssen
wir im lauf der 2020er beweisen dass es
funktioniert das können wir schaffen
sieht er wird bis 2025 das erste plasma
produzieren das ist der zeitplan den wir
einhalten müssen das alles ist möglich
es wird geschehen
[Musik]
nach rund zehnjähriger vorbereitungen
rollen die großen bauteile aus aller
welt an aber trotz präziseste planung
gibt es eine sache mit der selbst die
klügsten köpfe der branche nicht rechnen
konnten eine welt im lock down
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicolae leiter der technischen abteilung
und chef des montage prozesses ist
hindernisse gewohnt und nimmt das
problem gelassen
[Musik]
und wie ist etr mit 19 fertig geworden
wir haben neue und andere arbeitsweisen
entdeckt sehr wahrscheinlich werden wir
unsere lehren daraus ziehen die anzahl
der mitarbeiter auf der baustelle wurde
um ein drittel reduziert trotzdem
konnten wir die hauptaktivitäten
weiterführen
[Musik]
auf der ingenieursunternehmen des
wissenschafts und betriebsebene gingen
alle ins home office
in gewisser hinsicht war das nichts
neues denn die ita organisation ist über
die ganze welt verteilt sowie wir sind
es gewohnt aus der ferne zu arbeiten
wir versuchen das zu leben was wir die
neue normalität
denn in gewisser weise funktioniert es
der bau des weltgrößten fusionsreaktors
ein projekt der superlative
die drei riesigen bauteile für den
kinostart sind schon fertig allein der
sockel wiegt
1250 tonnen
daraus einen reaktor zu bauen ist eine
weitere technische mega aufgabe
wie transportiert man solche ungetüme
und wie kommen sie an ihren endgültigen
platz in der reaktorhallen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für dieses ungewöhnliche problem braucht
es eine ungewöhnliche lösung
neben dem reaktorgebäude wird eine
riesige montagehalle errichtet darin
werden zwei kräne installiert beide in
der lage jeweils 1.500 tonnen zu heben
sie manövrieren ihre wertvolle fracht
vorsichtig in die sogenannte zuckermarkt
probe
ein symbolträchtiger moment denn er ist
der beginn des montage prozesses
die presse und das ist die präzision die
wir brauchen diese elemente diese
riesigen platten bewegen sich nur
zentimeter
[Musik]
es ist entscheidend dass der cruze tat
socke genau an der richtigen stelle
positioniert wird
um ihn herum wird der rest der reaktor
komponenten montiert
bauteile an denen ein jahrzehnt
gearbeitet wurde
bauteile die millimetergenau konstruiert
wurden damit sie zusammenpassen ohne
wenn und aber alles muss exakt passen
wenn wir nicht sicher sind ob etwas
perfektes müssen wir es sofort
überprüfen damit sich gar nicht erst
fehler einschleichen
der sonst funktioniert das ganze am ende
des tages nicht dem ziel es ist wie beim
turm von pisa wenn sie nicht aufpassen
steht er am ende schief
sobald die konstruktion über der tokamak
oben schwebt wird sie ganz langsam
abgesenkt ein mühsamer prozess der
äußerste präzision verlangt
[Musik]
wenn die ganze zeit über wird
kontrolliert sie schön wenn man davor
steht sieht man fast keine bewegung es
geht nur millimeterweise voran lieferte
wirklich beeindruckend
[Musik]
ein großteil des riesigen reaktors ist
bereits vor ort aber noch stehen
komplizierte transporter an einige davon
mit einer gewaltigen ladung mehr als 400
tonnen schwer
und der hafen ist mehr als 100 kilometer
entfernt bei der planung stellte man
fest dass keine existierende rote den
gewaltigen dimensionen gewachsen war
so wurden straßen verbreitert kreuzungen
ausgebaut und sogar ein teil einer
klippe entfernt
[Musik]
zudem hoffe ich erleichtert bin wenn wir
es geschafft haben klar mehr als
erleichtert
[Musik]
jetzt kann die montage beginnen obwohl
es noch ein paar jahre dauern wird bis
der riesige reaktor in betrieb geht für
die wissenschaftler und ingenieure auf
der ganzen welt die seit über einem
halben jahrhundert daran arbeiten ist
dies ein meilenstein in der geschichte
der kernfusion verwendet für mich ist
dies das ende eines sehr langen weges es
erfüllt mich mit einem gewissen stolz
dass wir es tatsächlich geschafft haben
alles ist da wurde es kann losgehen ohne
co wird 19 hätte es heute eine große
feier gegeben in anwesenheit führender
politiker und der internationalen presse
aber in mancher hinsicht ist die kleine
ansammlung von wissenschaftlern die es
heute hier ja geschafft haben viel
passender sind menschen die ihr leben
lang auf dieses ziel hingearbeitet haben
und sie sind sich bewusst dass sie den
staffelstab bald an die nächste
generation weitergeben werden
ich würde gerne noch fünf jahre dabei
bleiben von den startknopf drücken und
sehen ob es funktioniert
es ist eine enorme herausforderung für
unsere generation und für kommende
generation ich hoffe dass die menschen
begeistert sind von dem was wir hier bei
uns unterstützen sich aber auch selbst
engagiert sie sollen ingenieure werden
und wissenschaftler damit wir den
planeten retten können
[Musik]
ich habe das gefühl einen beitrag
geleistet zu haben zusammen mit
tausenden von wissenschaftlern formiert
und tausenden von weiteren in der
zukunft zusammen schaffen wir eine neue
energiequelle
[Musik]
warum tue ich das ich tue es für meine
kinder ich bin davon überzeugt dass das
der richtige weg ist unsere zukunft
probleme zu lösen
ich schämte mich zusätzlich zu den
erneuerbaren
energiemix
es gibt nichts anderes ist das so große
mengen an energie liefert bei so
geringen auswirkungen auf die umwelt
[Musik]
als ich ein kind war traf ich einige der
ingenieure das apollo projekt das fand
ich wirklich cool am apollo projekt zu
arbeiten einen menschen auf den mond zu
bringen das hier ist das gleiche ich
kann sagen ich habe geholfen dieses ding
zu bauen ich habe der menschheit
geholfen die energie krise zu überwinden
und das ist wirklich toll
[Musik]